coal may have returned to the
neighborhoods of romania and chief but
lebanon is still on the edge deadly
clashes on thursday really brought the
country uh to the brink scenes were
reminiscent of the civil war
yes we talk about neighborhoods but
they're also strongholds strongholds of
political parties long time enemies who
do not see eye to eye on how this
country should be governed the crisis is
not over the guns may have fallen silent
there seems to have been an undeclared
truth did the both sides decide to hold
fire because they realized that they
raised the stakes too high and the
danger of the country sliding into
all-out conflict was there but right now
it seems that lebanon is finding itself
in yet another political crisis it was
only a month ago that the politicians
reached an agreement on a new government
after 13 months of paralysis and the
government is needed in order to engage
in negotiations with the international
community on a bailout plan to save the
economy but amal and hezbollah the shia
political parties who called for the
protest yesterday and who are demanding
that the judge leading the investigation
into last year's vader court explosion
is removed have not backed down they're
insisting he must resign or he must be
removed and
they're threatening that they will not
attend cabinet sessions and they'll
they'll pull out of cabinet and if they
do that means an entire sect is not
represented and according to lebanon's
sectarian power sharing agreement
cabinet will not be able uh to govern so
political paralysis will politicians be
able to find a deal will be tar
be quote and quote sacrificed um that
would mean for many at least in the
opposition that hezbollah and amal got
their way they've been criticized for
carrying out a coup
carrying out a coup against the
judiciary
their opponents say why don't you wait
why don't you wait for the results of
the investigation before you judge uh
vitar and his investigation really a
deep political crisis that has spilled
onto the streets a dangerous escalation
on the streets but right now
there is a political crisis and many
many fear that
thursday's battles could just be round
one if there is no solution to this
crisis